kim kardashian and kanye west reunite to
pay their respects to the late virgil
ablo at his final louis vuitton show in
miami
kim may have filed for divorce from the
grammy winner back in february but on
tuesday the two came together for a
special occasion a showing of the former
artistic director's spring summer 2022
collection marking his final
presentation the exes posed for this
pick with their eight-year-old daughter
north and the kkw beauty founder shared
several moments from the night on her
insta story including a giant hot air
balloon with the louis vuitton logo a
statue of virgil a fireworks show and a
drone choreographed light show with an
animated paper plane before revealing
the words virgil was here in the sky and
i love that the off-white founder and
artistic director for louis vuitton died
over the weekend following a private
two-year battle with cancer he was 41
years old following news of his passing
stars like drake haley bieber gigi hadid
kendall jenner tracy ellis ross idris
elba pharrell and more share their
condolences on social media kim posted
several pics with virgil to instagram
writing in part quote this one is hard
to process i can't even believe i am
writing this we will miss you so much
virgil and love you so much
but kim and kanye weren't the only stars
in attendance at tuesday's event maluma
ricky martin 21 savage lil baby gunna
and metro boomin were there while cuevo
kid cudi and offset modeled in the
runway show
[Music]
[Laughter]
and in a post to louis vuitton's
instagram page michael burke the
chairman and ceo explained it was the
designer's wish for the show to go on
quote virgil was not only a friend great
collaborator creative genius visionary
and disruptor but also one of the best
cultural communicators of our time he
paved the way for future generations
michael added that virgil was a quote
eternal optimist who believed anything
was possible in this same spirit we at
louis vuitton will proudly continue to
celebrate his legacy with a final show
in miami her his wishes
[Music]
and in a live stream the show closed out
by sharing some sweet words from virgil
himself there's no limit
life is so short
that
you can't waste even a day
subscribing to what someone thinks you
can do versus knowing what you can do
you